En fait, nous sommes même prospères,
et la raison de cette prospérité, est que nous sommes bénis :
nos rois sont extraordinaires.
Nos monarques éclairés ont travaillé sans relâche
pour développer notre pays,
équilibrant soigneusement croissance économique
développement social, durabilité environnementale,
et préservation culturelle,
le tout dans le cadre d’une bonne gouvernance.
Nous nommons cette approche holistique du développement
le « Bonheur national brut », ou BNB.
Dans les années 70,
notre 4ème roi fut célèbre pour avoir formulé que pour le Bhoutan,
le Bonheur national brut
est plus important que le Produit national brut (PNB).
(Applaudissements)
Depuis,
tout développement au Bhoutan est piloté par le BNB,
une vision pionnière qui cible l’augmentation du bonheur
et le bien-être de notre peuple.
Mais c’est plus simple à dire qu’à faire,
surtout lorsque vous êtes l’une des plus petites économies au monde.
Notre PIB est inférieur à deux milliards de dollars.
Je sais que certains d’entre vous dans la salle valent plus --
(Rires)
individuellement
que l’économie entière de mon pays.
Ainsi notre économie est petite,
mais c’est justement cela qui est intéressant.
L'éducation est intégralement gratuite.
Chaque citoyen est garanti d’avoir une scolarité gratuite,
ceux qui travaillent dur font des études universitaires gratuites.
Les soins de santé aussi sont gratuits.
Les consultations médicales, les traitements, les médicaments :
tout est pris en charge par l'État.
Nous arrivons à le faire
car nous utilisons très soigneusement nos ressources limitées,
et, car nous restons fidèles à la mission essentielle du PNB,
qui est le développement mais avec des valeurs.
Notre économie est petite et nous devons la renforcer.
La croissance économique est importante,
mais pas au détriment de notre culture singulière
ou de notre environnement vierge.
Aujourd’hui, notre culture est florissante.
Nous continuons à fêter notre art et notre architecture,
notre gastronomie et nos festivals,
nos moines et nos monastères.
Et, oui, nous célébrons aussi notre costume national.
Voilà pourquoi je porte mon gho avec fierté.
Voici un fait amusant :
ce que vous voyez est la plus grande poche au monde.
(Rires)
Elle commence ici,
passe par derrière,
et finit ici, à l’intérieur.
Dans cette poche,
nous rangeons toutes sortes d’effets personnels :
téléphone, porte-feuilles,
iPad, dossiers ou livres,
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais parfois --
parfois aussi une cargaison précieuse.
Notre culture est donc florissante,
ainsi que notre environnement.
72 % de notre pays est recouvert de forêts.
Notre constitution exige qu’au minimum 60 %
de la surface totale du Bhoutan soit recouverte de forêts
pour toujours.
(Applaudissements)
Notre constitution,
cette constitution,
nous impose une couverture forestière.
Incidemment, notre roi a utilisé cette constitution
pour nous imposer la démocratie.
Vous voyez, nous, le peuple, nous ne voulions pas de la démocratie.
Nous ne l’avons pas demandée, nous ne l’avons pas exigée,
et nous ne nous sommes pas battus pour l’obtenir.
Notre roi nous a imposé notre démocratie
en insistant pour l’inclure dans la constitution.
Et il ne s’est pas arrêté là.
Il a inclus dans la constitution des dispositions
qui donnent au peuple le pouvoir d’accuser ses rois,
et des dispositions qui obligent chaque roi à prendre sa retraite
à l’âge de 65 ans.
(Applaudissements)
Le fait est que nous avons déjà un roi à la retraite :
nous précédent roi, le « Grand Quatrième »,
a pris sa retraite voici 10 ans,
au sommet de sa popularité.
Il avait alors 51 ans.
Alors, comme je le disais,
72 % de notre pays est recouvert par des forêts,
et toutes ces forêts sont vierges.
C’est pourquoi nous sommes l’un des derniers
hauts lieux de la biodiversité au monde,
et c’est pourquoi nous sommes un pays neutre en carbone.
Dans un monde menacé par le changement climatique,
nous sommes un pays neutre en carbone.
Il s'avère que c'est important.
Parmi les 200 et quelques pays que compte le monde,
il semble que nous soyons le seul
qui soit neutre en carbone.
D’ailleurs, ce n’est pas tout à fait exact.
Le Bhoutan n’est pas neutre en carbone.
L’empreinte carbone du Bhoutan est négative.
Notre pays émet 2,2 millions de tonnes de dioxyde de carbone,
mais nos forêts en fixent plus du triple.
Nous sommes donc un puits net de carbone
pour plus de 4 millions de tonnes de dioxyde de carbone par an.
Et ce n’est pas tout.
(Applaudissements)
Nous exportons la majeure partie de l’électricité renouvelable
produite grâce à nos rivières au cours rapide.
Alors de nos jours, l’énergie propre que nous exportons
compense environ 6 millions de tonnes de dioxyde carbone pour nos pays voisins.
D’ici 2020, nous exporterons suffisamment d’électricité
pour compenser 17 millions de tonnes de dioxyde de carbone.
Et si nous exploitions la moitié de notre potentiel hydroélectrique,
et c’est précisément notre objectif,
l’énergie propre et verte que nous exporterions
compenserait environ 50 millions de tonnes de dioxyde de carbone par an.
C’est plus de CO2 que celui produit par une ville comme New-York en un an.
Donc, à l’intérieur de notre pays se trouve un puits net de carbone.
À l'extérieur, nous compensons du carbone.
Et c'est important.
Vous voyez, le monde se réchauffe
et le changement climatique est une réalité.
Il affecte mon pays.
Nos glaciers fondent,
entraînant des crues subites et des glissements de terrain,
qui entraînent aussi catastrophes et dégâts énormes dans notre pays.
Récemment, j’étais au bord de ce lac.
C'’est étourdissant.
Voilà à quoi il ressemblait voici 10 ans.
Et voilà à quoi il ressemblait il y a 20 ans.
Il y a tout juste 20 ans, ce lac n’existait pas.
C’était un glacier.
Il y a quelques années, un lac similaire
a détruit son barrage.
et a semé le chaos dans les vallées en dessous.
Ces dégâts ont été causés par un seul lac glaciaire.
Nous avons à composer avec 2 700 d’entre eux.
Ce que je veux vous dire, c’est que
mon pays et mon peuple n'ont rien fait
pour contribuer au réchauffement climatique,
mais nous sommes déjà touchés par ses conséquences.
Et pour un pays petit et pauvre, un pays enclavé et montagneux,
c’est très difficile.
Mais nous n’allons pas nous tourner les pouces.
Nous lutterons contre le réchauffement climatique.
C’est pourquoi nous avons promis de rester neutre en carbone.
Nous avons initié cette promesse en 2009
durant la COP 15 à Copenhague,
mais personne ne l’a remarqué.
Les gouvernements étaient trop occupés à se disputer entre eux,
à blâmer l’autre de causer le réchauffement climatique,
alors quand un petit pays a levé la main et a annoncé :
« Nous promettons de toujours rester neutre en carbone. »
Personne ne nous a entendus.
Personne n'a fait attention.
En décembre dernier à Paris,
lors de la COP 21, nous avons réitéré notre promesse
de toujours rester neutre en carbone.
Cette fois-ci, nous avons été entendus.
Nous avons été remarqués et tout le monde a fait attention.
Paris fut différent car les gouvernements se sont réunis
pour accepter les réalités du changement climatique,
ils étaient prêts à se réunir pour agir et travailler ensemble.
Tous les pays, du plus petit au plus grand,
se sont engagés à réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
La Convention cadre des Nations Unies sur le changement climatique
a déclaré que si ces soi-disant engagements étaient respectés,
nous pourrions limiter le réchauffement climatique
à 2°C.
D’ailleurs,
j'ai demandé aux organisateurs de TED
d’augmenter le chauffage de cette salle de 2°C,
alors si certains ont un peu plus chaud que d’habitude,
vous savez qui blâmer.
Il est crucial que chacun respecte ses engagements.
En ce qui concerne le Bhoutan,
nous tiendrons notre promesse de rester neutre en carbone.
Voici les moyens pour nous d’y parvenir.
Nous fournissons de l’électricité gratuite à nos agriculteurs.
L’idée est qu’une électricité gratuite, leur évitera d’utiliser le feu de bois
pour cuisiner.
Nous investissons dans le transport durable
et nous subventionnons l’achat de véhicules électriques.
Similairement, nous subventionnons le coût des ampoules LED,
et tout le gouvernement tente d’atteindre le zéro papier.
Notre pays est nettoyé
grâce à notre programme national « Clean Bhoutan »,
et nous plantons des arbres partout dans le pays
avec « Green Bhoutan »,
un autre programme national.
Mais ce sont nos régions protégées
qui sont au cœur de notre stratégie de neutralité carbone.
Nos régions protégées sont nos puits de carbone.
Ce sont nos poumons.
À ce jour, plus de la moitié de notre pays est protégée,
par des parcs nationaux, des réserves naturelles
et des sanctuaires fauniques.
Mais le plus beau,
c’est que nous les avons connectés les uns avec les autres
par un réseau de corridors écologiques.
Cela signifie
que nos animaux sont libres de se déplacer à travers notre pays.
Ce tigre, par exemple.
Il a été repéré à 250 mètres au-dessus du niveau de la mer
dans les chaudes jungles subtropicales.
Deux ans plus tard, ce même tigre
est repéré à près de 4 000 mètres d'altitude
dans nos froides montagnes alpines.
N’est-ce pas génial ?
(Applaudissements)
Nous devons continuer sur ce chemin.
Nous devons continuer à avoir nos parcs géniaux.
Chaque année, des ressources sont économisées
pour empêcher le braconnage, la chasse,
l'exploitation minière et la pollution dans nos parcs,
et d’autres ressources aident les communautés qui vivent dedans
à gérer leurs forêts,
s'adapter au changement climatique,
et avoir une meilleur vie en continuant à vivre en harmonie avec Mère Nature.
Mais cela coûte cher.
Dans les prochaines années, notre économie manquera des ressources nécessaires
pour couvrir les coûts de protection de notre environnement.
En fait, quand on fait le calcul,
il nous faudrait au moins 15 ans
avant de pouvoir financer entièrement nos efforts de conservation.
Mais ni le Bhoutan,
ni le monde,
peuvent se permettre de passer 15 ans à reculons.
Voila pourquoi Sa Majesté le roi a lancé
« Bhutan For Life » (Bhoutan pour la vie).
Bhutan For Life nous donne le temps nécessaire.
Il nous donne une marge de manœuvre.
C'est essentiellement un mécanisme de financement
pour veiller sur nos parcs,
les protéger,
jusqu’à ce que notre gouvernement prenne seul le relai.
L’idée consiste à lever un fonds de transition
grâce à des donateurs individuels, des entreprises et des institutions,
mais le contrat ne sera signé que si les conditions prédéfinies sont respectées
et que tous les fonds sont engagés.
Ainsi plusieurs parties prenantes, un unique contrat ;
une idée que nous avons empruntée à Wall Street.
Ainsi les donateurs individuels peuvent s’engager sans craindre
de participer à un plan insuffisamment financé.
Un peu comme un projet chez Kickstarter,
mais qui s’étale sur 15 ans
et avec des millions de tonnes de dioxyde de carbone en jeu.
Une fois l'affaire conclue,
nous utiliserons ce fonds de transition pour protéger nos parcs,
donnant à notre gouvernement le temps d’augmenter notre autofinancement
jusqu'à la fin de la période de 15 ans.
Ensuite, notre gouvernement pourra garantir un autofinancement pour toujours.
Nous y sommes presque.
Nous prévoyons de conclure cette année.
Bien sûr, je suis assez impatient.
(Applaudissements)
Le Fonds mondial pour la nature (WWF) est notre partenaire principal dans ce voyage,
et je voudrais leur exprimer ma grande reconnaissance
pour leur excellent travail au Bhoutan
et partout dans le monde.
(Applaudissements)
Il commence à faire vraiment chaud ici.
Je vous remercie d’avoir écouté notre histoire,
une histoire sur comment nous respectons notre promesse
de rester neutre en carbone,
une histoire qui raconte comment nous maintenons notre pays vierge,
pour nous-mêmes, pour nos enfants,
pour vos enfants et pour le monde.
Mais nous ne sommes pas ici pour raconter des histoires.
Nous sommes ici pour rêver ensemble.
Alors, je voudrais partager avec vous un dernier rêve.
Et si on pouvait mobiliser notre leadership et nos ressources,
notre influence et notre passion,
pour reproduire le projet Bhutan For Life dans d’autres pays
afin qu'eux aussi
puissent conserver leurs régions protégées pour toujours.
Après tout, beaucoup de pays font face aux mêmes problèmes que nous.
Eux aussi, ils ont des ressources naturelles
qui peuvent nous aider dans la lutte mondiale pour la durabilité,
mais ils ne sont peut-être pas en capacité d’investir dès maintenant.
Si nous mettions en place « Earth For Life » (la Terre pour la vie),
un fonds international pour lancer Bhutan For Life à travers le monde ?
Je vous invite à m’aider
à porter ce rêve au-delà de nos frontières,
à tous ceux qui se sentent concernés par le futur de notre planète.
Après tout, nous sommes ici pour rêver ensemble,
pour travailler ensemble,
pour lutter contre le réchauffement climatique
et pour protéger notre planète ensemble.
Parce que la réalité des choses,
c'est que nous sommes tous dans le même bateau.
Nous avons peut-être des styles vestimentaires différents,
mais nous sommes tous dans le même bateau.
Merci beaucoup,
et kadrin chhe la. Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, merci, merci.